Tyreke or all right finally that's asked
the reviewer segment I guess but
tomorrow Hussein in the UK is obviously
not here it's pretty late their time
watching yeah I'm going to kind of ask
you guys about Pete you and I have
played the game I played it a preview
events probably like three total hours
maybe at this point um say or the phone
yeah you've been following the game for
a while I guess everybody has just you
know it's got the you know fune a name
attached to it but uh so what did what
do you think of the game yeah what
you've seen but following for a while
and i think it was around III when i
started to hear things about it that got
me really interested yes i like keiji
inafune is a older work but armature
studios you know they're involved in
this and those are made from a lot of X
people who made Metroid Prime at retro
so then I started to hear the game is
sort of like it feels like a 32 128-bit
game like you know I playstation 2 error
kind of action game and that sounds
appealing because things have become
kind of bloated and you know in a sense
so to revisit that old style of gameplay
sounded really fun tomorrow's review
basically described a game that is what
i was looking for until the very end
where he ended up getting to a point
like every other reviewer where you've
essentially finished the campaign by
going through you know quest by quest
and then it's like we need you to
backtrack and collect items that are
hard to find you do that and it's like I
need you to do it again but get more
this time and that process repeats
itself that sounds kind of crappy so
anyway I spent about half hour with the
game playing it myself before coming on
here which isn't enough to get a really
great impression but mechanically like
moment to moment it feels pretty good
but I did encounter two bugs that have
to restart the game within 30 minutes
one of them within five minutes but one
you showed me was essentially the world
itself had gone white yeah or you're on
like a cliff on the edge of a white
abyss I finished the first boss fight
and I walk out and I see this hill and
then beyond that is just white and I
thought oh this is gonna teach me to air
dash to some random thing that I can't
quite see and I was like no wait there
are things just walking in midair and I
was like oh yeah I there's nothing in
front of me the game has not rendered
the world around yeah but before that
there's a mission where you're trying to
dash through a door you stand on a
pressure-sensitive button you have to
dash fast enough so you get to the door
before it closes once you step off I
apparently was like just at the right
time for the door to catch me Dennis
Lottie in the drum in the geometry above
the door and I couldn't get out so I i
had an autosave which is fine had to
exit but this is a game that also has a
like really long loading screens and
kind of take all this to account you
take the padding into account as well
and you've got a game that that's really
rough around the edges it seems based on
my experience and base what a lot of
people are reporting including two more
yeah he said there were about four big
bugs he encountered on xbox one during
his play for sure yeah um again it's a
budget price game it's only forty
dollars which probably means something
to you know a lot of people who kind of
like way how much they want to spend and
it sounds like you'll get about you know
eight to ten hours of like a decent game
but but one that clearly maybe could
have benefited from a little bit more
time and attention towards the end game
which kind of puts your back against a
wall it makes you complete chores it
felt repetitive to me from the few hours
i played obviously like a big part you
upgrade her jewels rifle jewel being the
protagonist but then eventually you'll
find enemies that are like kind of
different color like red yellow or blue
and you just press a direction on the
d-pad to switch to that color of
ammunition because that happens to be
the weakness of that colored enemy and i
feel like that was a very lazy attempt
to upset the gameplay but then you
obviously like the driving force being
you're customizing your different cores
right the yeah i think the cores being
those actual spheres they give it the
personality but then you can put
different frames on it so there's like
the dog that stuns people there's the
bigger gorilla i think that his name is
duncan duncan that you could be like
hammers on his arms and whatnot and make
him he's like the brute and then there's
the spider one that like kind of
ziplines you around so that was the
driving aspect for me is kind of
customizing them because there is like a
loot fest kind of aspect too there's
different colored Luthi actually pick up
to customize them with i'm not sure if
that plays into upgrading the rifle but
i think the main thing is like obviously
like we interviewed asian affluent
recently and at a certain point where
like is the mega mega man legacy kind of
actually negatively impacting your
future projects because everybody's
expecting them to be similar because a
lot of people said this is like a 3d
megaman combined with metroid prime
which the metroid prime aspect was more
appealing to me but it doesn't sound
like that really came
because like you said the item gating
later on is like the specific quest
items you need to go back and just like
tediously search for rather than like
metroid prime which actually like you've
got a new item that affected how you
play and how you fight enemies but then
you just happen to come into a part of
the world that you've been before and
you're like oh now i can do this this
sounds more tedious and i don't know
that that's appealing to me at all i
don't want to get to the late game then
realize i have to go back and find one
more of these cores and God knows where
it is this might be one of those games
where you don't need to beat it like you
can feel good about just getting to a
certain point and being like yeah that's
fine I mean after a half hour I kind of
want to keep playing I like the way
movement feels I like the way shooting
feels it's it's auto Liam but there's
something to be said for that because it
opens you up to greater mobility and
enemies can force you to move around a
lot more but you can keep you know the
action going well that's all happening
so I find that kind of encouraging and I
do see that I do see the kind of Megaman
combat in the sense that you're jumping
and dodging him there and then you're
dodging and kind of coming back around
to shoot cash or other side and that did
seem like an engaging gameplay loop I
don't know how much it would how long
it'll asset for me after that you know
like our long preview I played yeah I
mean I think at this point we should
okay he's not helping his case with a
game like mighty number 9 but it'd
probably be healthy if people could look
past megaman when looking at something
keiji inafune e does sure I think
because Mega Man has influenced so many
things that we now take for granted in
games that's really easy to just look at
that and say oh yeah there's the
connection definitely um but I don't
think it hurts her or benefits the game
in this case necessarily i think this
game kind of stands on its own and i was
like the narrative or story to say i was
really interested in and what were these
balls of energy that are mac and all
these characters is there like an
explanation some some of like a dust
that what they call the dust devils
stormers only that took out the world or
so from what I understand yeah it's
pretty much kind of like an interstellar
thing where jewel has come to the planet
to try to find new colonize abul planets
for humanity from one understand and she
kind of comes with the stuff planted
starts to discover things that she
didn't expect to be here I don't know
where how the chorus planned oh I just
think that they're like the source of
energy on this particular planet but I
didn't play enough to really get into
the narrative
I know tomorrow was saying something
spectacular but it drives the action for
it I guess as far as like you know just
making it a vehicle for the combat
that's great I i don't know that i find
the world looks kind of like that
borderlands one like I get sick of the
desert after a while sure it doesn't
look vibrant now that every game needs
to be in late like I said this makes
sense it's just us plenty like this
decrepit kind of a barren place but I
don't know it looks like it may be over
eight hours it would get annoying but I
don't know doesn't seem particular
interesting to me damn yeah well I don't
know from what I play the game it does
get kind of got tough later game we
played late-game missions and we were
the people we being the people that I
was playing with that I gamescom we were
playing in a lot of us died in this the
developers are saying a lot of times
they'll just say oh you're the only one
to beat it to make you feel better maybe
we'll write a better preview but I'm
seeing people died left and right around
me the monitors are right next to me and
it got tough I mean you're balancing
shooting these different guys who it
kind of became like a you know shooting
it like sponge sponge bob bosses
whatever later on and it did feel like
it could like I said we're thin after a
while I think tamura said it does a
pretty good job introducing new wrinkles
to actually keep it somewhat interesting
throughout but yeah I don't know I don't
have any immediate draw to the game
right now yeah so that's two more
Hussein who reviewed it's a six on
gamespot you can read the full review in
the meantime that is on xbox one and pc
yes and you get a crawl it's cross by so
you buy a woman get both cool yeah so
yeah play it on windows 10 or xbox one